i think 10 or 20 years ago
women had to make a conscious choice
between being a wife
mother a homemaker or having a
professional career
but we aren't willing to be forced into
that choice
and i think our classmates respect us
for it
[Music]
hi susie how are you i'm great hi
barbara hi anne this is so exciting
to be doing this interview together and
be reunited
wonderful what a treat
barbara ann and i had the good fortune
even though we were only
three of five women in our class of mbas
which
numbered about 308
the visionary dean of the stanford
business school gary williams who
admitted us
he put three of us in the same section
and that gave barbara ann and i a chance
to
become close friends and so
at the end of the first year based on
our closeness
we volunteered to do a class project on
marketing
deciding we needed to educate the school
the faculty
the administrators and our fellow
students about what our experience was
like because it was a very compelling
unique experience to be that small a
minority
in a environment that was dominated by
men
we started interviewing one another
taking pictures the full title
is what's a nice girl like you
doing in a place like this that's
exactly the question
that faculty administrators and fellow
students pose to us
for myself it's not that i find
homemaking an inferior role for women
it's simply that i believe that women
should have the freedom to choose
other roles if that's what they'd like
to do if that's where their
talents and interests lie there were
indeed males
in our class who just oozed confidence
and it's expressed in that question
what's a nice girl like you doing in a
place like this
they clearly felt they had every right
in the world
and we solely because we were women
did not i don't mean to be glib
but to me it's when did i take them
seriously
i don't think it really got to me what
were the first couple of months like in
business school
um they were a shock i'm about 10 years
older than either susie or anne
and i had worked for a number of years
in
the real world i was surprised
first of all to be in a room that was
nearly all men
and deeply grateful to see susie and
anne
the camaraderie with barbara and anne
was immediately
helpful i walked into one
class i think it was econ the very first
week of school first year
and the professor turned to me in front
of the
all the students who had already arrived
and he said
you're an mba and from the back row
came this voice she sure
is and that was my future friend
ann thornton i love that susie that's
great
i remember when we got back our first
accounting exams
and the professor put the curve up on
the board
someone from the back of the room
shouted out well how did women's lib do
and suddenly everyone in the room knew
our scores
we really weren't allowed to be
anonymous
people were very interested in our
performance
and perhaps they felt a little
threatened by us
i just had to adapt at the business
school to this
reality that many did not have the same
positive expectations for my success in
the world of
work and in leadership but my family
background my undergraduate
peers ann and barbara
that helped me we were the unusual ones
we were in the unexpected place doing
the unexpected thing
luckily the young culture does not
engage in the kind of discrimination
that the older culture is doing so
i think that it's going to be better it
just seemed that people were saying
things don't have to be the way they've
always been and i think that
the politics of that time i think that's
what
inspired all of us i mean you know this
was
60s 70s and we we thought we could
change the world and we kind of did in
some ways
the curriculum at the stanford business
school at the
time it was actually still an
informative stage and there were
very few women who were
presented as leaders in the case studies
certainly our case studies here at the
business school
have shown us only women who are doing
mindless assembly
line work and who are unable to relate
to other women
except in the most superficial sorts of
ways
and i think that if we can present
ourselves as real people in this program
then maybe they'll understand this
better
[Music]
i felt people began taking me seriously
after we did the marketing presentation
i really felt that we found many
fellow students who became truly great
friends
who saw us as individuals sauce as we
saw ourselves
and that made a big difference
[Music]
and i hope you realize how much your
support
meant to me when we were new students at
the business school and part of
this very very tiny minority you were
able and
to deal so well with these questions
about why we were there
and i took so much encouragement from
that and
barbara it was great for ann and i
to be a close friend to and fellow
student
with a woman who'd made her way in the
business world and
had a lot of wisdom to share with us you
know barbara's no one's fool
and so she always said it like it was
and she always proved herself thank you
if i had a chance to talk to the woman
i was when we made that program i would
tell her to keep doing what she was
doing
she was on the right track she'd have a
wonderful career
she'd always be very grateful for her
stanford graduate school of business
education it was going to
all pay off i would do it again and i
would say
go for it you have nothing to lose now
if i could go back
and talk to myself knowing now what
i've seen in the last 50 years i would
say
hey lady stand up it's your
responsibility
you're good at it go ahead
you